KRISH SRINIVASAN:
Good afternoon.
I'm Krish Srinivasan.
I head the Cloud and Compute
Organization at Target.
For those who shop at Target
and for those who love shopping
at Target, I'm sure you
know that we are all
about inspiration and joy.
And for those who don't
know about Target,
we are one of the biggest
retailers in the US,
across 50 states.
And I have a simple proposition
that I want to start with.
Any organization that wants
to serve its customers
or is thinking about
customer satisfaction
has to think about
inspiration and joy.
Now how many of us
from an IT standpoint
think inspiration and joy?
At Target, we do.
Technology has been a key
factor behind Target's growth
over the last few years.
And we are just getting started.
See it's even more critical
because if your goal is
to be America's
easiest place to shop,
technology becomes a
foundational stone for us.
Now having said that,
we know that our guests
have high expectations.
They want us to do well.
They believe in us.
They're rooting for us.
They want us to innovate.
And simply, they just
want us to be Target.
So with all these
high expectations,
how do we look up and out
from a technology standpoint?
How do we make sure that we
build the right platforms
and capabilities from an
infrastructure standpoint,
so that we are ready for a
future guest when they come up
with those new experiences,
or when they're looking
for those new experiences?
And that's what I'm going
to talk about today.
Last year our CIO Mike McNamara
was at this very event.
And he shared the business
strategy and the technology
transformation at Target.
As Mike stated, our
strategy is indeed working.
And cloud is an enabler.
And thank you to
Google for being
part of the journey as well.
In fact, this is our
fifth straight year
where we are growing
25% year over year.
And I'm happy to say that last
year was the first year where
we ran 100% of our
Cloud Commerce workload
on Google Cloud Platform.
So Google, thank you
for a flawless holiday
season in 2018.
Together, we came together,
and we provided our guests
some phenomenal experiences.
Now what you see
in the screen is
these are industry leading
fulfillment services
for our guest.
And we're just adding
on more and more to it.
Couple of examples,
let's say you're at work,
and you want to make that order.
You are looking for something.
But you don't have the
patience to wait for two days.
You have the capability
now to make that order
online from your work and pick
it up on your way back home.
What about this?
A busy mom, it's raining.
She has two little ones,
little ones in her backseat.
And one of them is starting
to throw some tantrums.
The other one's begin--
starts to begin to meltdown.
And I know some of
us have been there.
She does not have to
get out of her car.
And what we have done is we have
given that mom the capability
to punch in that order,
and when she drives
her car to the parking
lot, our team members
get notified through a
geo-location service.
And within two minutes,
our store team members
will come and place the
order in the car trunk.
And these are the
experiences that we are
talking about in the future.
Now how did we get here?
I would say there are three
foundational principles
at Target we believe in.
First, technology has to
be experience focused.
Now what do I mean by that?
At Target, experiences takes
first before technology does.
All of us have been an incident,
outages and operational cause.
Something happens,
we get on a call.
And this is where typical
IT organization do,
there is a server failure.
There's a database failure.
Or some software
developer over there
did a full table
scan, brought out--
brought down an application.
At Target, we look at it
a little bit different.
When we have an outage or
an incident at Target, yes,
all of us do get on the call.
But the first question
we ask is, what
is the impact to the guest?
What is the impact
to the team member?
We understand that very clearly.
And then we talk about, what
is the technical or technology
issues?
Second, architecture must be
simple, elegant, and adaptive.
And what I mean by that is
when we write applications
at Target, we want
to make sure that we
don't have a vendor lock-in.
and there is this
foundational principle
that platforms are the path to
the future and not just tools.
And the third thing
I would say is,
technology has to embrace
cloud and open source, which
is why we went with Google.
Now we all know
that cloud gives us
the speed and agility
and elasticity and all
that good stuff.
But what about open source?
At Target, when we
have a solution,
and we're looking for a
solution for a problem,
the first thing we
do is internally
look inside and see whether
we can repurpose a solution
that we already have.
If for some reason
that's not available,
we then go to the
open-source community.
And we look at it.
And if for some reason
that's not available,
we then go ahead and
write it on our own,
even before we go
to the vendors.
And the best part
is, once we write it,
we contribute back to the
open-source community.
So I talked about these
high expectations earlier
that guests have in us.
They want us to do well.
They want us to be Target.
They want us to innovate.
This is where the next
chapter of innovation
comes in that I talked
about earlier, which
is all about focusing on our
guest and our team members
in the future.
Be it a quart of milk, or
that beautiful rug you're
looking at, or that perfect
gift that you want for somebody,
Target is a positive force
behind millions of people
in the US every single day.
Now we have about 30 million of
our guests shop at our stores
every month, about 100 million
visits in our digital fronts.
So to do this, we operate
in at about 1,850 stores.
We have 29-- or 39
distribution centers.
We have our own
two data centers.
And yes, we also have
Google Cloud as well.
But-- and here's the
challenge that comes in--
what if-- what if all
these assets came together
seamlessly?
What if I could take
a workload and just
deploy it across the board?
And what if I don't look at
these 1850 stores as stores,
but I look at them as yet
another extension of my cloud.
So tomorrow, I'm not
going to have just GCP.
I may have 1,850
cloud environments,
just think about that
power, and the capability,
and the scalability
that we can get.
And what if there
is a scenario where
I have five stores in New York,
three stores in San Francisco,
I want to do two
pilots the same day.
I get the results back.
And I pick one of them,
because one has a better
experience for a guest.
And within a few hours,
what if I can just
deploy to 1,850 stores across
the hundreds of thousands
of devices that are
running in those stores?
We have close to 130,000
Android mobile devices that
are running in those stores.
And what if I can
do that seamlessly?
And here's the best part,
what if I could do everything
that I said and still
make the underlying
infrastructure completely
invisible to our engineers?
So they are focused on
what they're good at, which
is to write great software
that can delight our guests
and make our team members happy.
They don't have to worry about
the underlying technology.
patches, the version upgrades.
We take care of all of that.
And that's what we have
been working on at Target.
Our engineers have been hard
at work for the last 18 months,
building this platform at Target
to solve this exact challenge
for the future.
Within Target we call
it as TAP, or T-A-P,
which stands for Target
Application Platform.
The mission of this
platform is very simple.
It's to make Target the best
place to write and deliver
software with zero
touch infrastructure.
So in closing, I want to go
back to my initial proposition
that I made, that
any organization that
wants to provide
great customer service
must focus on
inspiration and joy.
Our guests get
inspiration and joy
from our products and
services, which they love.
And they're rooting for us.
Our store team members
get inspiration and joy
by delivering those
services to our guests.
Our technology team members
get inspiration and joy
by building and innovating for
the next set of experiences.
And that's the thing
about inspiration and joy,
when it's going great, you get
to renew it every single day.
And that's what we do at Target.
And we are just getting started.
Thank you, and have a
wonderful conference.
[MUSIC PLAYING]